bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti era un
altro episodio di guido troll facebook
di m2 questo credo sia the walking dead
desideri queste che è roll
questo è un m16 perfetto come sparo io
quando gioco a call of duty stessa cosa
ovviamente non doveva andare così
proprio in modo diverso elettrico
cerotto non le tolgono che la smettiamo
di sparare ok non ho capito questo fatto
ma fa niente
speriamo che sia finito qua perché non
so cosa ho fatto non saprei di farlo
perfetto andiamo al bar bol
questo meme un gatto con la pistola non
so se è un bene ma è la cosa più bella
che abbia mai visto allora gatto deve
uscire per forza va bene andiamo avanti
ragazzi non ho capito niente ma va bene
così e normale che io non riesca più c'è
qualcosa nel tombino c'è una cosa in
tobino c'è qualcosa nel tombino c'è
qualcosa nel tombino c'è qualcosa nel
tombino
c'è qualcosa ma come si muoveva come
possibile smettetela di mo limonare voi
due sembriamo il giulia penale vito di
gabry ponte nord dove te dove c'è
qualcosa nel tuo parco demonio su come
devono cadere di sotto ma anche questa è
un'ottima c'è chi sta questo sono io
quando mi provo nei vestiti costosi nei
negozi e poi non li compro quello dentro
ma cosa sto vedendo malgioglio ma cos'è
vabbè non ho capito niente ma andiamo
avanti
[Musica]
qualcuno mi spiega la faccenda perché
non stavo capendo 996 66 al contrario
attenzione qualcuno me l'ha spiega poi
sta roba perché non capisco che serie tv
come me dovrebbe essere in tutto questo
continua a cliccare lui no non ho capito
dovevo tenere però ho capito adesso o
non ho capito il bello visto gioco che
capisci cosa hai fatto dopo stavo io
stavo pensando di tutto questo non stavo
neanche cercando di farlo
sto pensando perché no anche questo
gioco si debba pensare però chelyabinsk
con miley cyrus va bene ai che mi laica
non hanno sfondato niente quindi c'è
sempre qualcosa che non vende in tutto
sto bordello
questa l'avevo anche già fatta porco
sono passati 60 anni dall'ultima trovata
proprio disco in questa roba l'avevo
anche fatta io non me le ricordo raga
non me le ricordo scorso episodio c'è
questo e doctor who credo spero sono
concesso così che si muove non me lo
spiego dove lo devo portare quello a
cagato e basta però secondo me devo
spostarlo domina a loro apporto o lo
cappottato senza un motivo
tutto a posto benetton atomi non ho
niente va bene così
non fate domande ragazzi o hamburgeria
bene fai due per favore anche a me
piacerebbe no niente chiuso ma sa che
non ho capito come cacchio faccio
[Musica]
questo potrebbe essere usato come di
singh ha un sacco di gente però ne
avanti no raga non sto più inseguendo
niente queste cose di the sims che con
un cappello cazzo ridi
non so più seguendo nulla fa le magie
qualcuno mi dica che serie tv hockenheim
e questo lager male di giorno non ce
l'ho presente mai ora come si sta
cagando al corso l'altro credo che io
non debba far trasformare nessuno a
questo punto però non so come ossia no
forse metterli trasformo fedele succede
qualcos'altro aspetta no non succede
niente maledizione
ok allora lui a posto a posso anche
prenderlo e metterlo su di lei no e
mettono su di lui
su di lui se un bellissimo unicorno se
doveste sincero sarei andato tutto
triste va bene
justin bieber huston beaver ok questa
che lecca lecca lecca questo qua ego
simulator e questo è una pedata quindi
ah ecco e mo esatto
e uguale un miliardo di light moglie
eccoli dichiara vale di più di un
miliardo ci si azzecca va anche numero 1
100 miliardi light perfetta next me ne
mancano 2000 e ci siamo ragazzi abbiamo
finito quasi come finire l'università
comunque livello è quello è scomparso
sto coso anzi ha cambiato colore non ne
capisco il motivo è uscito io sapevo
tutto è andata esattamente come volevo
the last one ragazzi super mario è un
gameplay supermario evidente riprendere
cose non è quello c'era un grande stato
fare è veramente di servizio che kate
mario ancora peggio lo sposto lo metto
io dentro lo spostamento al posto del
gameplay così c'è lui a fare una cosa e
quindi è morto le mie abilità
videoludiche arrivano anche a questo
better control ma non era finito 37 gen
sono 39 a ok allora abbiamo ancora due
già fatta c'è forse ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi o li sto passato tutti al primo
tentativo su un fenomeno
affettare cinguettare e mangiare se
riusciamo a affettiamo tutto e mettiamo
dentro fin che mettiamo dentro questo è
sicuro ok ora c'è un altro passaggio
coltello non era il coltello ma vabbè mi
piace che c'entra sempre il musone
scatarra the sull'insalata sino non lo
fate sto scherzando perché è sempre
buona l'insalata con
con lo straccio sici così in piemonte
non so da voi game of thrones come
ultimo mi sembra ovvio vediamo che
cacchio perfetto per adattare no sai che
non è giusto non è giusto però che ci
deve saltare sopra è sicuro poi devo
cambiare il trono se non è un trono di
merda dell'italia chiedevo cambiare il
trono non ci piove devo solo capire come
sono trascino non lo trascino ma va bene
il crono di forbici
o è giusto ma cos'è
ma cos'è il trono delle acconciature era
anche un po una merda se posso
permettere in prova signori questo era
il fis quest video memes finito grazie a
dio siamo oltre la sapienza umana
immagino che più di così ci sia solo la
biochimica
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa di
origine momento è un bel mi piace anche
per i social che mi ha dato notizia nei
sensi rischiate i ragazzi e noi
cerchiamo al prossimo tris questo non ci
sono ancora un sacco nuovissimi che devo
fare questi alcuni livelli avevo già
fatti sono alcuni ragazzi
[Musica]